ce soir en fait j'ai décidé de vous
parler du temps de l'oeuvre d'art et du
regard la phrase que j'ai prise comme
intitulé c'est le regardeur qui fait
l'oeuvre est une phrase énoncée par
marcel duchamp qui est un artiste majeur
du début du 20e siècle et dont on a eu
la chance en fait d'avoir une de ses
oeuvres principales qui celle-ci
fountain 1917 qui est un urinoir
inverser la phrase de marcel duchamp
c'est le regardeur qui fait l'oeuvre
devrait pour moi être dessus de chaque
port d'entrée des 1250 musées en france
rappelait que le regardeur le visiteur
est actif c'est lui qui va mener
l'oeuvre qui va prendre le temps qui
parmi vous s'est rendu dans un musée
ces douze derniers mois
c'est pas mal vous étiez pas tout seul
sur ces dernières années la progression
des visiteurs dans les musées français
est absolument exponentielle 2 millions
de personnes en plus chaque année
quasiment l'équivalent de la population
française rentre dans un musée en france
tous les ans ça fait plus de 60 millions
de personnes
pourtant on rentre dans les musées mais
qu'est ce que l'on y fait depuis une
trentaine d'années on observe en fait
des études sur vous visiteurs de musées
sur nous quand on rentre dans un musée
on est observé un peu disséqués moi ça
fait 15 ans que je suis médiateurs
culturels
ça fait quinze ans que j'aime m'asseoir
dans une salle regardez les visiteurs
circulent et regarder les visiteurs voir
et surtout c'est un petit peu un discret
joue la corde
regardez les visiteurs discuter échanger
mais une chose assez incroyable c'est
que dans ces études paraissent des
chiffres absolument improbable en 1992
nous avons eu en fait une étude faite au
louvre dans une salle la salle
néoclassique sur 134 visiteurs et ils
ont chronométré chronométrer le temps de
regard de chaque visiteur qui s'arrête
au moins devant une oeuvre dans cette
salle chronométrage assez étonnant
qu'ils prenaient en compte la lecture ce
qu'on appelle l'étiquette
si vous n'êtes jamais rentré dans un
musée souvent il ya une oeuvre et à côté
il ya un petit truc comme ça
et quand on donne les statistiques pour
préciser les choses ça donne ceci ingres
la grande odalisque le chiffre qui
m'intéresse c'est celui ci 9 secondes et
15 centièmes
en lisant le cartel la grande risque
c'est cette oeuvre la pauvre majeur
d'ingres peintres du début du 19e siècle
en oeuvre selon le 15 centièmes je ne
pense pas on voit que cette jeune femme
a un gros souci de deux vertèbres en
plus ou bien encore une jambe plus
courte que l'eau oui mieux
toujours dans la même étude le tableau
du temps et là on à david grand maître
du néo classique
david fait les sabines le temps cette
fois c'est aussi racé au départ un peu
mieux parlons en un peu mieux 40
secondes pour cette oeuvre la 40
secondes pour une oeuvre qui mesure
trois mètres 22 sur cinq mètres 40
ça fait à peu près en fait 35
centimètres carrés d'oeuvre vues en une
seconde sans voix un peu on va dire ça
comme ça
regarder l'oeuvre c'est une vraie
problématique prendre le temps pour la
regarder
c'est nécessaire une oeuvre elle a trois
temps celui de création celui
d'exposition et celui de monstration et
dans ces trois temps l'artiste
intervient dans deux sa réalisation son
accrochage mais dans le troisième temps
c'est à nous d'agir
c'est à nous de devenir spectacteurs de
love on est dans sa voix et quand on
prend que 10 secondes et demie scellé ce
qu'est sorti de cette étude
face à une oeuvre dans un musée c'est
court trop court pour qu'une relation
s'engage il faut prendre le temps du
regard
il faut prendre le temps de se poser sur
l'ensemble quand vous avez la joconde
oui je pense que dans le monde la
connaît ou bien encore carré noir sur
fond blanc de quasi lien malige
ce sont deux offres qui semblent
totalement aux antipodes de ce que peut
nous proposer l'armée qui ont exactement
la même vocation celle de nous proposer
un temps de regards qui salon
un temps d'observation devenons
regardeur de ses oeuvres pour en
comprendre ce qu'elles ont à nous dire
réellement mais en 10 secondes et demi
c'est pas possible je vais vous raconter
une petite histoire moi que je trouve
extrêmement intéressante un peu vieille
la joconde en août 1911 il y à une
affaire d'état énorme
la joconde est présenté au loup
magnifiquement sur les cimaises un matin
on ouvre le louvre et voilà ce qu'on
trouve en août 1911 on a volé la joconde
au louvre
c'est en août au mois de décembre le
musée du louvre des sites d'accrocher à
sa place ce magnifique portrait de
baldassari castiglioni fait par raphaël
mais qu'y at il au mur du mois d'août au
mois de décembre rien et du mois d'août
au mois de décembre 1911 à paris il y à
une foule immense qui se rend au musée
du louvre
voire rien oui on va y avoir un mur vide
où il y a juste la petite étiquette qui
dit la joconde
donc on rentre dans le lourd dit tiens
je vais voir la joconde elle le compte
n'y est pas alors qu'on va pas jouer
avec cet éloge à la joconde ya pas
l'ajout combat bref étonnant et on est
rentré dans le musée et en et
comptabilise autre petite histoire
aujourd'hui la joconde et là je suis pas
convaincu que quand on rentre au musée
du louvre pour se voir la joconde
on va là locaux nouvelle espèce d'énorme
mausolée race et de culture on va pas la
volée on ne voit quasiment plus ce
tableau est en fait on se dit tiens je
suis allé voir la joconde
quand on serait allé voir guy tente
rapidement et on ne prend pas le temps
plus proche de nous en touraine
une aventure dans les années 90 si vous
ne connaissez pas il s'agit de rembrandt
la fuite en egypte
c'est une des pièces maîtresses de la
collection du musée des beaux-arts de
tours
mais cette pièce a eu un problème avec
ceux ci il y à tous les cinq ans une
grosse réunion du comité rembrandt qui
repense les attributions des tableaux de
l'artiste en mettant un peu en cause
dirons nous si c'est bon ou pas alors le
petit cartel qui est ici présentée
pendant longtemps ce 6 avril à rembrandt
la fuite en egypte ces 127 les années 90
le comité en vendée c'est peut-être pas
brands on va leur est attribuée et hop
le cartel devient sa ouest émois de
l'amour c'est gérard d'où un élève de
rembrandt pas trop connus et bien d'un
seul coup le tableau devient moins
intéressant pour ceux qui viennent le
voir au musée
ah oui ce qu'on connaît le
fonctionnement on a tous dans un musée
on rentre on regarde le tableau est rien
elle vous fait la même chose aux autres
et gérard doux ok bon jeu je passe
pourtant l'oeuvre
c'est la même c'est le même sujet elle
n'a pas changé elle n'a pas bougé elle a
exactement la même composition mais le
petit cartel à côté le gérard doux à
changer notre regard sur l'oeuvre on
visite les musées comme on lit en fait
un inventaire ou une liste de courses on
regarde simplement le nom on dit ah oui
on regarde le titre et on regarde
l'année
c'est ce que j'appelle moi la règle des
3 q qui quoiqu'en qui prendront quoi la
fuite en egypte allait 727 et hop on
passe
c'est un petit peu moi je trouve comme
si on était invités imagine où nous
sommes invités à aller dans une des
meilleures caves réserve de vin en
france
tous les plus grands crus les meilleures
années s'ils battent pour essayer de
d'être devant les autres on nous invite
à une dégustation dit venez déguster ses
meilleurs crus parmi là et on rentre
dans la cave et on lit tout et
étiquettes on ressort une heure après la
can on a bu 0 goutte de vin on dirait un
merveilleux j'ai déguster des crus
superbe ça m'étonnerait si on ne savoure
pas le vin en ouvrant la bouteille c'est
la même chose si on ne prend pas le
temps quand on est face à un tableau
simplement prendre le temps de poser son
regard prendre le temps de construire sa
relation change radicalement la façon
dont on peut l'observer quand nous avons
un tableau comme celui-ci chefs-d'oeuvre
du musée des beaux-arts de tours
chef-d'oeuvre de la renaissance à
l'international mantegna merveilleuse à
titre de l'homme le christ au jardin des
oliviers au diable ces bons choquée j'ai
le crij et le jardin des oliviers
passons
oui sauf que vous avez raté le tir a pas
oui le petit a pas hélas alors je vais
vous aider
il est là en dix mois et demi on rate le
lapin si mince j'ai raté le lapin de
mantegna ya mieux
on a raté les olives ouais les olives un
peu grosse il est des livres comme sale
avantage c'est que si vous invitez des
amis chez vous l'apéritif c'est une
olive 15 personnes a ouï dire qu'on est
fondamentalement lié à cet élément ou si
on ne regarde que ce qui se passe et
qu'on ne regarde pas le reste ça sert à
quoi
pourquoi monter gnahoré fait des petits
lapins des olives et cetera il les a
faits parce que à ce moment là on prend
conscience qu'il faut se délecter de la
peinture prendre son temps il y a deux
penseurs que j'aime particulièrement
l'un à ses proches de nous qui
s'appelait roland barthes qui était au
xxème siècle qu'avait dit le savoir la
sagesse c'est pas un pouvoir c'est pas
attendre savoir que ça c'est pas tant de
sagesse que cela c'est le plus de saveur
possible il y en a un autre un peu moins
connus du ovalie genova moine dominicain
du xiiie siècle donc 700 en avant qui a
dit ceux qui résident dans l'image c'est
trois choses
l'instruction la mémoire et pour que ces
deux premiers éléments soit activée il
faut absolument qu'il suscite de
l'émotion saveurs émotions sont des
choses souvent qu'on oublie un musée
c'est un lieu de savoir c'est un lieu
d'enseignement mais un musée c'est un
lieu de plaisir
c'est ça quand même la base revenons à
lui rembrandt et bien à rembrandt je
vous rassure on a trouvé un monogramme
en bas rh 727 c'est définitif
on ne changera pas le cartel la fuite
d'egypte boudiba la fuite au gibolin
papa maman le fils pas en egypte scène
un peu clair obscur dramatique de cet
exil et à la perceuse
la perceuse sur le pagne à l'arrière de
l'âne en fait attention à ce que la
vidéoprojection c'est bien mais ce
tableau et mesure 20 cm de côté en vrai
la perceuse c'est à peine 2 cm et
pourtant cette perceuse elle a un grand
rôle extrêmement important
la perceuse c'est ce qui définit la
catégorie socioprofessionnelle de joseph
il est charpentier csip que joseph en
étant charpentier c'est un homme
ce qui fait que d'un seul coup ce qui
est une iconographie religieuse touche
tout le monde
quelles que soient ses croyances parce
que c'est simplement une famille qui se
met sur le chemin de l'exil
un charpentier qui prend ses outils et
donc du coup vous pouvez même par les
bricolages dans les musées avec une
chignole c'est réellement comme cela est
étonnamment si on court à travers les
salles qu'est ce qu'on y voit
alors évidemment tous les artistes du
xviie xviiie travail une peinture
figurative aux ja plus je me rapproche
du tableau plus cnet alors ça marche pas
toutes les périodes la cathédrale de
rouen
menés là si vous vous rapprochez même au
plus près la gargouille vous leurrez pas
mais quand vous allez vous rapprocher du
tableau de monet
qu'est ce que vous allez voir dans cette
cathédrale de rouen une lumière qui
vibre de la couleur une touche monnaie
qui se trouve derrière son sujet monnet
qui retranscrit ce qu'il a perçu qui
veut nous faire vibrer et donc
évidemment on n'est pas là pour voir que
la cathédrale de rouen
nous sommes là pour voir monnaies et si
on avance encore dans l'histoire de
l'art est un choc
on va quitter le figuratif malevitch
1915 carré noir sur fond blanc
on va se dire tout de suite comment l
avantage c'est que ce qui est marquée
sur le tard tél mais ce qui est sûr le
tableau c'est à peu près similaire
effectivement on va pas chercher le
petit lapin on cherche pas la perceuse
et on cherche pas la gargouille mais
pourtant fait ce tableau a énormément de
choses à nous apprendre
parce qu'en prenant le temps il va se
dévoiler alors malevitch est allé plus
loin que carré noir sur fond blanc
vous avez carré blanc sur fond blanc
le carré il est légèrement bleu clair
ici et on n'est pas loin de ce qu'on
appelle le monochrome
quand on voit un monochrome 11 il ya
rien à voir avec de la couleur mais si
on revient en fait à carré noir sur fond
blanc
on découvre que c'est une oeuvre qui
présente deux problèmes d'abord le carré
n'est pas carré vous allez me dis ouais
mais est-ce qu'il faut que je rentre
avec mon double décimètre dans le musée
comme sa tante et non s'arrête un peu
complexe ça s'appelle un quadrangle et
la deuxième chose c'est que c'est une
oeuvre qui présentent des craquelures
beaucoup de craquelures dans toute la
partie centrale
voyez ici ici parce qu'en fait il n'a
pas directement peint sur le fond blanc
son carré noir il la peint sur une autre
toile malevitch à cette époque là il
fait des choses comme ça sert qu'il
expérimente ils cherchent des formes
géométriques colorées la plupart d'entre
elles évidemment 1918 la photographie
couleur c'est un peu compliqué et il
essaye en fait de trouver la solution de
cette réduction de la forme
et puis bah y trouve la solution il
repeint en noir
une oeuvre qui était déjà réalisée et si
d'un seul coup on s'arrête sur 7
si d'un seul coup on prend le temps ces
craquelures nous dévoile autre chose
qu'un degré d'usure et nous dévoile en
fait tout ce qu'il ya derrière le carré
noir
on peut même y discerner des couleurs un
peu de rouge un peu de bleu au centre et
corps d'un seul conseiller tiens je vais
voir autre chose que le carénage et
prendre le temps
on comprend que l'oeuvre à nous expose
sa vie elle nous expose comment elle
s'est construite et d'un seul coup on
commence à dialoguer et week-end carré
noir sur fond blanc de kasimir malevitch
qui est une oeuvre très réduite
c'est une invitation à se dire comment
est il arrivé jusque là et il n'y a pas
besoin de se projeter dans un livre et
il n'y a pas besoin de se lancer dans
une étude sur le suprématisme il suffit
juste de regarder prendre ce temps les
musées c'est un lieu où l'on rentre pour
le plaisir
ne l'oubliez jamais et surtout c'est que
quand on est face à une oeuvre le
premier temps ça sera toujours le regard
et ce premier regard c'est comme dans
une relation amoureuse
c'est un moment de saisir un moment de
suspension ensuite comme dans toute
relation amoureuse balla y aura de
l'amour
voilà il y aura de l'analyse tu auras de
l'approfondissement
mais pour se donner le temps de regarder
l'oeuvre
on va construire son regard prendre ce
temps de regard c'est aujourd'hui une
chance que l'on a face à une oeuvre
d'art quand vous avez un artiste une
oeuvre et un regardeur vous avez la
symbiose parfaite d'un apport mutuelle
et ce premier temps de regard c'est ce
qui fera faits et a fait l'oeuvre ne
l'oublié pas merci